bonjour et bienvenue dans fit l'écho ce
nouveau numéro est consacré aux
constructeurs automobiles fiat le
directeur france de la marque va nous
dévoiler les secrets de son succès nous
découvrirons aussi l'école de formation
technique et puis nous reviendrons sur
le mondial de l'auto 2012 où fiat
étaient bien évidemment présents alors
fietz et la célèbre marque de turin qui
a été créé en 1899 par giovanni agnelli
elle est toujours détenu par la famille
agnelli avec un chiffre d'affaires de
plus de 59 milliards d'euros en 2011
chiffre d'affaires de l'ensemble du
groupe fiat
un chiffre en augmentation patrice
duclos bonjour bonjour il était
directeur donc de la marque fiat en
france comment se porte globalement la
marque aujourd'hui globalement la marque
se porte bien comme vous l'avez dit d'un
point de vue mondial le groupe est en
forme on est dans une période européenne
comme tout le monde sait où beaucoup de
constructeurs sont bousculés par la
crise économique et une fiat sa part des
difficultés évidemment pour autant nous
avons pas mal de nouveautés en ce moment
qui nous permette un petit peu de tenir
la barre quelles sont ces nouveautés
parce qu'on pense spontanément à la fiat
500 est-ce que c'est celle qui marche le
mieux déjà aujourd'hui la fiat 500 est
une voiture qui fonctionne très bien et
déjà depuis cinq ans on va fêter le
millionième exemplaire au mois de
novembre
vendu donc c'est un vrai succès pour
autant d'autres succès sont en marche
on a notamment la nouvelle panda qu'on a
aussi lancé cette année
et puis la 500 elle qui annonce
l'agrandissement de la famille 500
combien de modèles dans la famille 500
pour l'instant alors aujourd'hui sous la
marque fiat de modèles donc la 500 que
tout le monde connaît dont vous parliez
et puis la 500 elle que nous avons lancé
la au mois d'octobre qui est une
extension on va dire plus familiale de
notre notre pot de yaourt telle qu'on
l'appelle en france est ce que certains
modèles se vendent mieux dans certaines
régions de france
oui globalement on va dire que fiat à
une meilleure pénétration dans le sud
comment le sud-est de la france proche
de l'italie certainement mais en tout
cas une vraie affection des gens du sud
pour la marque fiat
vous êtes installé à trappes depuis les
années 60 déjà pourquoi trappe et puis
est-ce qu'on produisait au départ des
voitures ici alors le groupe fiat est
installée ici oui depuis des années 60
avec notamment iveco
on n'a pas un produit de fiat ici il y
avait une production qui était lié à
l'activité camions
nous en tant que marque de véhicule
particulier nous sommes arrivés à la fin
des années 90 en 99 exactement
est ce qu'il y à une production en
france des voitures ch est non pas de
production en france
production en italie production en
europe de l'est et production sur le
continent américain
combien ce qu'il ya de salariés qui
attrapent plus globalement en france et
puis comment est organisée la marque
fiat alors la marque fiat ici compte à
peu près 200 personnes
je parle de l'entité fiat auto qui
englobe l'ensemble des forces terrain et
l'ensemble des forces présentes au siège
il ya quelques années on peut le dire la
marque fiat n'avait pas forcément une
bonne image en matière de fiabilité
on dit que les voitures craignent le
froid la pluie il ya eu un gros efforts
marketing de design d'image aussi est ce
que les mauvaises années sont derrière
vous will réputation et pas toujours
mérité donc ça fait bien longtemps que
comme ses concurrents les fiat ne
rouillent plus ou ne craignent plus
l'eau ni quoi que ce soit ça c'est une
vieille image installé sur le marché
français notamment
on combat ça et aujourd'hui la fiabilité
de nos produits
des montres complètement la qualité est
effectivement vous parliez
d'investissement ont fait pas
d'investissements principalement par
rapport à cette question de qualité
perçue ou de l'image générale de fiat
ont fait des investissements lui
générique qui porte l'image de nos
produits et on parlait de 500 tout à
l'heure on voit bien que tout cela
fonctionne et que personne ne rechigne à
acheter vous disiez en france cette
mauvaise presse qu'a pu avoir la marque
à un moment donné est ce qu'il ya
d'autres pays dans lesquels il n'y a pas
eu ce problème là forcément l'italie est
un pays qui n'a pas la même approche par
rapport à la mark pieth
mais évidemment que ce soit en allemagne
en angleterre la perception
d'automobiles est parfois différente et
on est dans un marché français où
plusieurs constructeurs nationaux
coexister donc la guerre est rude
c'est pour ça que peut-être en france on
a une réputation un peu plus difficile
comment se démarquer on se démarque par
les produits des voitures belles qui
véhicule un petit peu de dolce vita
comme la 500 voilà on reste ancré sur
nos bases italiennes
vous disiez la nouveauté un c'est là la
fiat 500 elle est ce qu'on peut attendre
d'autres nouveautés ce qu'il faut que la
marque aussi se repose sur sur des
nouveaux modèles
oui tout constructeur automobile a
besoin de nouveauté de plus en plus le
client est sensible renouvellement de
nos produits les cycles de production se
sont raccourcis et
et dans ce cadre-là fiat s'intègre
évidemment nous lançons par exemple une
déclinaison de la panda en quatre roues
motrices sont là on l'a vu au mondial de
l'auto elle a été présentée en première
mondiale
et puis l'année prochaine en fin d'année
prochaine on va encore avoir des
déclinaisons de la 500 elle que ce soit
en version trekking ou agression cette
place en 2014
une nouvelle déclinaison de la famille
500 que pour l'instant on appelle 500 x
donc voilà beaucoup de nouveautés qui
vont venir alimenter notre performance
je vous parlais du mondial de l'auto
2010 1,7 et porte de versailles au mois
d'octobre forcément vous y étiez vous
présentiez cette panda commence que ça
s'est passé ce mondial pour vous cette
année le monde elle s'est très bien
passé malgré un
un nombre de visiteurs un petit peu en
baisse on a globalement
reçu un très bon accueil pour la
première présentation de la 500 à elle
sur le marché français donc nous étions
très satisfaits des premiers contacts de
la perception produit c'était la mise à
l'épreuve pour ce modèle là et puis
comme je vous le disais la panda 4,4 que
là aussi nous avons présenté qui est un
petit peu plus orienté vers les régions
montagneuses
historiquement en france mais en tout
cas les gens qui ont pu la voir
ils ont bien apprécié et puis le reste
de la gamme mais c'est effectivement
présent c'est toujours à un moment
intéressant pour nous de se confronter
au jugement des clients alors c'est quoi
la fiat de demain je pense à
l'électrique et l'hybride la fièvre de
demain c
on a l'habitude de dire chez nous que la
technologie futur c'est la technologie
tout de suite pour le client donc
l'assiette de demain c'est c'est celle
qu'on présente aujourd'hui pour le
moment fiat est leader en termes
d'émissions de co2 en europe depuis
plusieurs années nous allons continuer à
travailler dans cette voie
après tout ce qui est approche plus
marketing des choses avec un travail
autour de l'électrique ce sont des
technologies que nous travaillons mais
que nous n'allons pas proposer
immédiatement en europe en tout cas
disponible pour le public
on travaille sur nos vraies nos vrais
points forts qu'ils sont petits modèles
et nos petites motorisations qu'elle
soit 10 elle ou essence leader en termes
d'émissions de co2 merci beaucoup
patrice duclos nous allons maintenant
aller au mondial de l'auto parce que
nous y étions pour voir les nouveautés
que vous proposiez plus d'un million
deux cent mille visiteurs se sont
pressés dans les allées du mondial de
l'auto qui se tenait porte de versailles
en octobre dernier une fréquentation en
légère baisse pour ce salon prisée où
les constructeurs automobiles viennent
présenter leurs nouveautés
c'était le cas de fiat qui agrandit sa
gamme 500 avec l'arrivée de l'a500 elle
destinée aux familles est disponible en
france depuis le mois d'octobre
c'est un véhicule qu'on a voulu très
émotionnelle sur les aspects coloris
elle reprend quelques éléments
esthétiques de la 500 notamment la
planche de bord couleur carrosserie mais
c'est avant tout un vécu qu'on a voulu
très rationnel et beaucoup
d'habitabilité de modularité de la
personnalisation et des tarifs et des
équipements à la hauteur
la marque italienne a également présenté
sa panda 4,4 troisième génération qui
est commercialisé depuis mi octobre
autre intérêt du salon pour les
constructeurs mettre en avant les
avancées techniques de leurs ingénieurs
notamment concernant l'électrique et
l'hybride un créneau que fiat n'exploite
peut-être pas autant que ses concurrents
nous continuons à travailler sur les
moteurs thermiques on pense que les
moteurs thermiques ont encore des
progrès à faire et notamment chez nous
avons développé un moteur bicylindre qui
s'appelle le twinair nous travaillons
également sur des carburants alternatifs
faut savoir que fiat est leader en
europe sur le gnv le méthane donc
d'éviter un camion encore plus propre
que les gpl et nous avons aussi une
large gamme de véhicules gpl
la 500 version électrique devrait faire
ses débuts aux etats-unis l'année
prochaine rien n'est encore prévu pour
l'europe
nous voici à présent à l'école de
formation technique de fiat
ici on s'occupe de fiat mais aussi des
sept autres marques du groupe je suis
avec jean françois taillefer bonjour
vous êtes directeur des services aux
clients concrètement qu'est ce qu'on y
fait dans cette école alors c'est pas
simplement un centre de formation c'est
surtout un pôle d'expertisé technique
dans lequel on a regroupé deux activités
une première activité qui est une
activité de formation technique pour
former les équipes techniques du réseau
et une deuxième activité qui est
l'assistance technique téléphonique dont
je vous parlais juste après combien
est-ce qu'il y ait de personnes qui
travaillent ici alors sur la partie
formateur on a six formateurs avec deux
encadrants et sur la partie assistance
technique on a neuf personnes comment
est ce que ça fonctionne concrètement
certes vous êtes en lien avec eux tour
tous les concessionnaires fiat de france
un technicien on doit savoir s'il est
capable ou pas capables d'intervenir sur
un véhicule
on commence par faire des tests de
compétences et en fonction de la
compétence du technicien
on va déterminer avec son
concessionnaire le travail qui lie à
faire pour l'amener au niveau de
qualification nécessaire pour qu'il
puisse intervenir sur l'ensemble de nos
vies
donc on fait de la formation sur mesure
et en détermine un plan de formation sur
toute l'année qui va permettre de le
faire progresser
sur l'ensemble des véhicules sur
lesquels il doit intervenir donc ils
pourront être formés tout au long de
leur carrière
absolument c'est un certain
développement c'est un cheminement qu'on
suit puisque le plan de formation qu'on
établit il n'a pas pour vocation à se
figer sur une année nos véhicules évolue
en permanence la technologie qu'on met
dans les voitures évoluent très vite et
on doit en permanence renouveler la
formation s'assurer que la formation n'a
pas été perdu et renouvelée en fait la
capacité technique de chaque technicien
savoir faire qui est en constante
progression
absolument parce que comme vous le savez
on a émis des dispositifs dans nos
véhicules pour la sécurité pour
l'environnement et qui nécessitent des
systèmes électroniques de plus en plus
pointues de plus en plus complexes nous
sommes très en avance sur l'ensemble des
technologiques ne mettons dans les
véhicules et donc en permanence on doit
s'assurer que le réseau suit cette
progression et que les techniciens ont
la capacité à réparer les voitures de
nos clients on le disait toutes les
marques du groupe fiat sont concernés
par cette école est ce qu'il y en a
certaines qui demande une attention
particulière non elles ont toutes leur
niveau de d'intelligence et de
complexité elles ont aussi pour
certaines des bases communes des besoins
clients qui peuvent différer fortement
mais sur le fond les technologies sont
des technologies de pointe que ce soit
pour les petits modèles comme pour les
gros modèles ce qui va changer c'est
peut-être le niveau d'équipement qui va
rendre encore plus complexe
l'intervention et qui va nécessiter un
savoir faire vraiment très aboutie de la
part des techniciens et nous nous
assurons que dans chacune de nos
concessions nous avons un texte qu'on
appelle tech plus qui est le super
technicien de l'atelier et qui va être
capable de répondre à toutes les
questions travail est aussi en lien avec
l'italie siège du groupe y est
absolument alors on travaille avec
l'italie à à deux niveaux le premier
niveau
c'est pour lé contenu des cursus de
formation puisque l'italie déploie les
véhicules c'est ce quelles sont les
nouvelles technologies qui vont être
implantés dans les véhicules et anticipe
bien entendu les cursus de formation
parce qu'à partir du moment où on lire
une voiture on doit être capable de la
réparer
et c'est notre engagement à nous en tant
que constructeur il ya aussi dans cette
école de formation des ingénieurs qui
travaillent à l'assistance technique
absolument donc ça c'est le deuxième
volet de notre activité parce que bien
que formé et ayant accès à une
information technique complète certains
techniciens peuvent être bloqués sur un
véhicule pour aller vite à la réparation
et pour les aider à aller plus vite on a
une équipe ici d'ingénieurs technique
qui va répondre en général en moyenne en
moins de deux heures à toutes les
questions qui sont posées par le réseau
et si d'aventuré on n'arrivait pas à
trouver la solution à distance on est
capable d'intervenir avec des experts
produits itinérant qui vont se rendre
sur site et intervenir avec le
technicien de la concession pour
solutionner le problème rencontré sur la
voiture de notre client est ce qu'il ya
des problèmes récurrents
alors on n'a pas vraiment à proprement
parler de problèmes récurrents dans
solutionner ce qui peut arriver par
contre c'est qu'on n'est pas la solution
à notre niveau et quand on n'a pas la
solution à notre niveau on a une
plateforme technique encore plus étoffée
en italie avec laquelle on est en lien
permanent qui va à l aller chercher des
solutions beaucoup plus profonde qui
vont valider la pérennité des solutions
apportées
merci beaucoup de gens pensent à
taillefer c'est moi qui vous remercie
avant de se quitter on jette un coup
d'oeil à l'agenda
la cité des métiers attrape organise une
journée de formation sur la formation en
alternance
lundi 3 décembre de 14h à 17h et la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles propose un atelier ressources
humaines
comment recruter efficacement en tpe pme
mardi 4 décembre de 8h30 à 12h à la
maison de l'emploi à trappes
c'est terminé pour ce numéro de file
echo je vous retrouve le vendredi 7
décembre pour un nouveau fil échos